qué cambios en materia económica
contempla la propuesta de constitución
que presentaron hoy en chile pues se lo
preguntamos entonces a jorge hurtado que
ya me acompaña aquí en el estudio de
directo américa buenas noches jorge qué
es lo que dice esta propuesta que dice
el documento bueno el principal cambio
está en un nuevo sistema de pensiones
que sería de forma pública allí es todo
después de la controversia con la famosa
afp que son estas instituciones privadas
que ofrecen el servicio de jubilación
allá en pensiones la actual constitución
y la nueva consagran el derecho a la
seguridad social esto significa que el
estado debe garantizar prestaciones
básicas otorgadas por instituciones
públicas o privadas las privadas en
chile son conocidas como ésta afp pero
la nueva constitución propone un sistema
de seguridad social público que sería
financiado con dinero de rentas
nacionales y cotizaciones obligatorias
pero no mencionan a prestadores privados
de la seguridad social en el nuevo
documento se lee que el dinero con el
que se va a financiar la seguridad
social no podrá ser destinado a otros
fines quedará exclusivo al pago de los
beneficios de la seguridad social que
sean establecidos el sistema de
pensiones de santiago en chile fue
instaurado durante la dictadura o
pinochet y es pionero en la
capitalización individual y obliga a
cada persona empleada a aportar el 10
por ciento de su salario mensual a un
fondo gestionado por estas empresas
privadas conocidas como las afp estas
empresas han sido fuertemente criticadas
por la escasez de pensiones que otorgan
en ese país la mitad de los
contribuyentes reciben menos de 215 mil
pesos o 280 dólares mensuales vamos a
cruzar los andes nos vamos hasta
argentina jorge porque allí operó con
volatilidad el mercado después de la
renuncia de el ministro de economía
martín guzmán que fue el sábado este fin
de semana y la designación un día
después el domingo de silvina batakis en
estos cambios en la dirección económica
de argentina hizo que el dólar blue se
disparara a más de 40 pesos y llegar a
los 280 por dólar aunque en el resto de
la jornada se moderó y se robó rondando
a los 260 la brecha cambiaria entre el
dólar informal y el tipo de cambio
oficial escaló hasta 106 4% es el nivel
más alto desde enero pasado entre los
restos de la nueva ministra o los retos
de la nueva ministra está la inflación
superior al 70 por ciento anual un
elevado déficit fiscal y un
estancamiento de la economía esto
mientras también intenta mantener vivo
el acuerdo de reestructuración de deuda
de 44 mil millones de dólares con el
fondo monetario internacional
lo hicimos en suramérica jorge hablamos
de perú allí continúa el paro de
transportes la huelga de transportistas
bueno se sabe que menos del 25 por
ciento del gremio del transportista
acató un nuevo paro nacional en ese país
aunque hubo normalidad en algunas partes
como 1 tacna y arequipa en otros puntos
y se registraron movilizaciones y
cierres de carreteras los manifestantes
en el agua las manifestaciones se dan
entre conversaciones con el gobierno que
hasta ahora se comprometió en incorporar
el transporte urbano el beneficio de
devolución del 70 por ciento del
impuesto selectivo de consumo
aplicable al combustible diésel hasta
diciembre del 2025 también se estableció
un beneficio económico temporal por
cuatro meses del 40 por ciento del monto
de los peajes para empresas de
transporte de carga inter provisional y
también las empresas de transporte
urbano esta es la segunda
del gremio de transportes que enfrenta
el presidente pedro castillo en sus 11
meses de gestión porque el presidente de
mexico cuando los manuel lópez obrador
anunció que noviembre va a realizar la
cumbre de líderes de américa del norte
de que van a hablar específicamente del
tratado entre méxico estados unidos y
canadá conocido como temer a dos años de
su implementación varios expertos hacen
un balance positivo de los efectos que
ha tenido en el comercio internacional
de méxico aunque todavía existen varios
temas que generan ciertos conflictos lo
más relevante en materia laboral por
ejemplo porque según méxico eeuu
distorsionan este tratado en ese ámbito
también hay quejas de parte de eeuu
contra las políticas energéticas que
favorecen a méxico y afectan los
acuerdos comerciales el 62% del comercio
en mexico se genera por las empresas de
manufactura es una quinta parte de la
generación del empleo formal en ese país
de la producción manufacturera en méxico
el 70% se consume en eeuu y el 30% en
europa justamente nos vamos para ese
continente de 'jorge el reino unido va a
introducir nuevas sanciones comerciales
y económicas y también al transporte
y todo esto por su apoyo o supuesto
apoyo a la invasión rusa en ucrania este
paquete de sanciones incluirá por
prohibiciones de importación y
exportación de bienes por valor de unos
73 millones de dólares incluyendo las
exportaciones de productos de refinado
de petróleo componentes de tecnología
avanzada y artículos de lujo así como
las importaciones de hierro y acero de
la russa anteriormente reino unido
aumentó los aranceles a las
importaciones de una serie de productos
procedentes de belarús en 35 puntos
porcentuales y sancionó al presidente
alexander lukashenko de alto funcionario
de ese gobierno ahora las instituciones
financieras británicas deben congelar
cualquier activo que tenga a nombre de
las empresas o personas sancionadas por
el gobierno cifra el día para el cierre
la cifra de 19 mil 700 dólares es el
precio del bit con hoy las perspectivas
de la reserva federal de eeuu y la caída
de los mercados de valores han
arrastrado los precios de la escrito
moneda de este año con los riesgos
sistémicos del mercado el bid coin ha
caído en lo que va del año un 56 por
ciento porque muchas gracias punto final
en economía a continuación el debate
aquí en directo américa
[Música]